i want to do just a brief interlude here
about my pillow ceo mike lindell this is
actually very interesting what's going
on
because it's bigger than pillow this is
about twitter
with the room it's not even really a
rumor with the news that in principle
elon musk is going to be buying twitter
although it's not been approved it may
fall apart and to be perfectly frank i'm
a little bit more and more and more in
the direction of this may this may never
happen but that's a story for a
different day there are lots of right
wingers that are sort of reinvigorated
who have been banned from twitter who
believe they're sure they're going to be
back on twitter that elon personally is
going to allow them back on twitter one
such person is my pillow ceo mike
lindell known colloquially as mike
pillow or just pillow for short
he
decided to evade his ban by creating a
new account and it lasted three hours
now remember even if elon musk plans to
unban pillow which we have no reason to
think uh at least at this point
elon musk is not in control right now a
business insider reporting lindell was
banned from twitter in 2021 over
election misinformation but rejoined the
platform sunday
the account was quickly banned for
violating twitter's ban evasion policy
jack dorsey should be first in line for
prison
lindell told insider business insider
via text
uh
hello everybody i'm back on twitter he
tweeted my only account is mike j
lindell
please retweet
follow to spread the word
the tweet also featured a video of
pillow confirming the account is his all
those other ones are fake accounts and
they've been using my name out there so
we started this account
please share it with everybody let
everybody know so we can get the word
out at twitter in case in case they do
take it down thanks a lot for helping
out
three and a half hours later the account
was suspended so twitter has what's
called a ban evasion policy and if
you've been banned you're not allowed to
attempt to evade it by making a similar
account like if my deepakman account was
banned it's not just the account it's me
as a person that is banned and we can
like it or we cannot like it and i'll
talk about that in a second i can't they
then go and create
dave pacman and if twitter finds out
that that's actually me uh of course
they they would be within their terms of
service to ban me again now i do want to
say something about these twitter bans
i am sensitive to the idea
that maybe there shouldn't be bans for
life
i i i could be convinced of that uh i
think that the trump ban was completely
correct and legitimate
i think that um the lindell ban was
completely correct and legitimate but
i would be open to the idea that the
maximum ban is a five-year ban or a
three-year ban i mean people do change
and i'm not saying trump will change but
also what's acceptable changes and great
examples are like on youtube
policies around many issues have changed
over time early in covid there was one
policy on covet material later it was
different um i i could go on you can get
the the idea it's sort of in a way i
mean
this isn't a serious i'm being honest
it's not a serious but
when when you
more seriously there are people doing
time for drug possession and later
the penalties for drug possession are
reduced or possession is decriminalized
or possession is legalized
and i think that that should be subject
to review and that's why i like it when
joe biden and others have uh kind of
gone back and exonerated or commuted
sentences on that basis so
i think there's a good case to be made
that the lifetime ban on twitter maybe
is a bit much maybe it should be three
years maybe five years or something like
that it is not currently the case and of
course pillow is evading the ban one
other thing on mike pillow here he was
interviewed at yesterday's trump rally
he says that he's spending 18 hours a
day on this trump reinstatement stuff
that's wild dominion and machines and
machines and uh you know it's been a
it's been a crazy year and a half but uh
how has your life changed personally i
know your business like and we'll get to
that special promotion you have for us
in a second but how has your personal
life changed since all of this i mean
it's 18 hours a day whereas you know i
miss my grandkids i miss my family you
know and uh and my niece and nephews we
i gotta take you know take advantage of
when i can but it's uh before i was i'm
so in the family and it's like i'm
pulled away from my home state of
minnesota he's spending 18 hours a day
going around talking about machines
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines and claiming that
we're just a week away from it all
coming out that that actually makes me a
little bit sad it really does i not
because pillow's a particularly good guy
uh but there's something a little bit
sad about that